[Music]
hello and welcome to the woman of Marvel
where we assembled to chat all things
Marvel and more I'm Judy and I'm sana
and today we have a really special
discussion celebrating Marvel Studios
ten-year anniversary and to do that
we've assembled some really incredible
women from Marvel Studios yeah this is
something that we've been wanting to do
for a few years so I'm actually really
excited to have three different women
who work in the different spectrums that
is filmmaking first and foremost we have
Heidi moneymaker
she is Scarlett Johansson stunt double I
mean she can get Oliver bug and then we
have Danielle Costa who is the VP of
visual effects for studios yes she makes
all those shiny films stuff happen like
like you know walking down the street
and suddenly a blue-screen or
green-screen becomes a street and then
finally but not least we have Wendy
Craig who is marble in house costumes
supervisor which we will talk a little
bit more about specifically what that is
so first of all ladies you guys are all
incredible and we're so happy to have
you here because as you know we
highlight all the powerful women who've
been working at Marvel so why don't you
each to tell us a little bit about how
you got to the career that you have and
specifically what true to Marvel in the
superhero world I was a gymnast for
pretty much all my life and earned a
scholarship to UCLA so I moved from
Northern California to Southern
California because obviously UCLA so in
that time I met quite a few people who
had gone through the UCLA gymnastics
team that had gotten into stunts here
they're in my fifth year of school when
I was done competing in gymnastics I
just started going out and on commercial
auditions and that kind of thing and
kind of got started that way so you have
been with with Scarlett yes since 2009
we started in 2009 beginning of 2009 I
mean it's been a while
and like four stands I feel like we talk
about stunts so generally but like what
is sort of like your day-to-day to like
to do the type of things that you need
to do one set you know it really depends
on the film you're doing or prepping for
most
a lot of you know regular physical
fitness I like to run so I run a lot
just you know keeping your cardio up but
sometimes you know I've had a couple of
films where there was a lot of driving
so it's very much dependent on your film
just a normal 9 to 5 job Daniel like you
so all these incredible fight scenes
everything that is being filmed footage
mm-hmm gets to you what do you do what's
what is what are the details of your job
the visual effects Department touches
almost every frame of every movie that
we do at this point the team it's it's
one of my favorite departments because
we are the one of the only teams that
starts at the beginning of prep and we
end at the end of finishing where we
carry the whole project through from the
beginning to the end the visual
development team starts by building you
know the first looks of the characters
and that's it sometimes that happens
before there's even a treatment of the
film the creative producing team kind of
starts to work the way into who the
characters are and then from there the
costume designer comes on and then the
hopefully the character gets cast and
then from there it depending on the
character we actually may play a big
role in in the design from everything
from the obvious which is like Thanos
and Hulk and the sea and rocket and the
CG characters but even from maybe what's
not so obvious like skinny Steve from
Captain America one so Wendy why don't
you tell us a little bit about what you
do and I work at the archive and and
when a movie is shooting and they say oh
we need the cost we need to look at the
costume from Thor to the one he wore in
the scene where this happened I run to
the continuity books and I look up that
and I go out into the archive and I pull
that costume and it goes to the movie
for their reference or were marketing
infinity war and the the premiere is
happening in the red carpet is happening
in there they want to put 21 costumes
that was
it was such a the emotional moment for
everybody to walk through the red carpet
and see what the what had been put
together and then that museum collection
of all of everyone from Heimdall from
the second Thor to spider-man to Doctor
Strange and quill and Gomorrah and Drax
and and everyone from the movie and
there they are on on mannequins now how
are they gonna up that for infinity war
two for like what no I'm saying that's a
question you guys have to ask yourselves
every single time you're on a new film
isn't it yeah hundred percent every
everyday kind of challenge I didn't make
it the same but different and better
right because you know that what you've
done people have loved right so you have
to sort of make it similar because you
know that works we have to change a
little bit and still make it better yep
it's crazy
so Wendy like you've worked on up you've
been in the industry for a while you've
worked on numerous films what is it
specifically that just drawn you to
Marvel Studios and to superheroes and I
think it's the question that's relevant
for all of you guys but why don't you
take that first well it was dumb luck at
first I been in film for a hundred years
yes and I worked the set and I started
supervising movies and then I got the
chance to supervise ant-man and I fell
in love I fell in love with the people I
fell in love with the the techniques of
building these costumes it it's art its
art and it's art that develops over the
course of the character run heidi what
about you your your connection to Marvel
films and BlackWidow in particular like
why do you think that characters so
significant the thing with the Black
Widow character I mean I've really
fallen in love with her over the years
for sure I think I heard you're not
Scarlett
fine but no the thing with with Black
Widow is she's such a prominent female
superhero in this universe and she's not
a superhero you know I mean she's she's
got no superhero power her power comes
from being this just fight or flight you
know work to survive through her whole
life right she's this little Russian
girl you know she's as good as she is
because she's had to work for it and it
would didn't and that's a superpower in
itself you know there's there's no
spider that bit her no offense
spider-man 11 but you know there's
nothing that like happened that she had
to be left to get used to being amazing
you know it was like she had to work and
become that superhero on her own so
that's that's why she resonates so much
with me
and that's like as you were saying
earlier like such a strong message for
little girls and women right yeah
absolutely you know if you want
something work for it you can achieve it
you know it doesn't come easy
and obviously Danielle like superheroes
sort of existed I know in like the
thousands but now they exist on a
different element
totally I know when I started at Marvel
which was around which is when you
started they it wasn't what it is now
by any means and there was I mean I
think by the end of Thor there were
rumors of this crazy idea of doing an
Avengers movie and we're gonna build
that I think that was maybe when I first
heard about it I did think that they
were crazy though I remember thinking at
the end of Thor like you people are nuts
possible to do we are never gonna finish
we have screwed ourselves we have put
everything at the end and guess what we
finished everything yes the joke's on me
and I had already you know done tons of
big tempo movies before and at that
point I had thought they had pushed it
way way past what every finish line that
I could conceive of and yet we still
finished I agree with you 100%
everybody's kind everybody is reasonable
and that is a great environment to work
in I feel like everyone sort of needs
like we talked a lot about having allies
and
finding the right people who are going
to help build you up so you guys are
sort of now that how do you like what
are the the pieces of advice that you
would give to the next generation of
people aspiring to be the future Heidi
Danielle and Wendy's of the world well I
would say there are no limits anything
is really achievable and I know that
sounds maybe silly but it's really not
and we know that from what we do that
you know she makes creatures that don't
exist and now they do you know they're
just like there there's no never put a
ceiling on anything never say I love to
do that but that's not something I can
do you know it's it's hard to say I
don't know if I have one piece of advice
I guess I would say you know be humble
work hard get your foot in the door
that's gonna be and when you're when
you're at the bottom of the rung prove
yourself you know get the coffee's do it
with a smile on your face that's those
are the people look around see what
needs to happen don't wait for people to
ask you to do things
be cognizant and we you think has to be
happening
those are the people who are naturally
leaders and who will eventually make
their way up on the ladder quickly just
you know be a hard worker pick up the
trash ya know I'm sure Pepper Potts and
sometimes you're just takin out the
trash you know it's true
I've always said you just you have to
work hard the more you know the more
employable you are so learn everything
that someone's willing to teach you and
[Music]
listen listen to what's going on around
you don't always think you have to be
the biggest voice in the room and I
think that's what's important is that
you know the thing the reason why we've
always sort of wanted to do this
conversation is that women work in this
industry and that like people at home
can know that there are opportunities
for them and it's never too late it's so
amazing to see the three of you you've
given such an incredibly important
contribution to Marvel Studios over the
last 10 years and beyond and hopefully
so so much more so thank you for for
sharing your thoughts and your insights
and hopefully you guys will come back
and hang out with us yeah thanks for
having us
another ten plus years of Marvel Studios
with some exciting movie as always if
you want to learn about the women of
marble head to marvel.com slash podcasts
I'm Judy I'm sana and this is Marvel
your universe
[Music]